hallo leute wollt ihr über euren urlaub
sprechen dann brauchte die passenden
lokalen präposition und davon gibt es im
deutschen ganz schön viele wir haben
dazu schon einige videos gedreht und
weil das thema so beliebt ist zeigen wir
euch heute nochmal die drei wichtigsten
positionen auf und in mit akkusativ und
dativ los geht's
wir beginnen mit der präposition an an
nutzt man wenn man zeigen möchte dass
man sich neben oder bei etwas befindet
waren benutzt an zum beispiel mit dem
substantiven das meer die küste der
strand oder der see
allerdings gibt es eine ausnahme beim
strand hier sagt man am strand obwohl
man sich nicht neben dem strand befindet
sondern physisch auf dem strand liegt
oder steht man sagt trotzdem nicht ich
liege auf dem strand sondern ich liege
am strand zuerst zeige ich euch die
präposition an mit dati vielleicht wisst
ihr es schon bei lokalen präposition mit
dativ geht es um eine position die frage
ist wo bist du dazu haben wir auch schon
mal ein video gedreht schaut mal hier
heimisch wie stan oder wo bist du
aber ist super ich bin am
klingt gut und was machst du gerade
ich sitze am strand mit beantwortet hier
zweimal die frage wo seine antworten
sind am meer und am strand er benutzt
den dativ hier noch ein wichtiger tipp
vielleicht habt ihr es gerade schon
gemerkt manchmal verbindet man die
präposition mit dem artikel
wir sagen nicht an den mehr sondern am
meer wir sagen nicht an das meer sondern
als leer und wir sagen nicht in das
gebirge sondern ins gebirge
jetzt zeigen wir euch ein beispiel für
an mit akkusativ die frage bei
präpositionen mit akkusativ ist immer
wohin wohin gehst du mit
wohin fahren wir in den urlaub die
forschende vielleicht an
schmidt wir wohnen am meer vielleicht
fahren wir ins gebirge
ich frage wohin fahren wir in den urlaub
mit antwortet ans meer das ist eine
bewegung zu einem anderen ort deshalb
nutzen wir den akkusativ
ich mache dann einen anderen vorschlag
auch im akkusativ ins gebirge
vielleicht fahren wir in die berge
übrigens wenn ihr noch intensiver
deutsch lernen möchtet dann werdet ein
mitglied von easy german die bekommt
dann zu jedem video ein work schied mit
einer vokabel liste und interaktiven
übungen
wir freuen uns wenn ihr teil unserer
community werdet wir machen weiter mit
der präposition auf auf nutzt man wenn
man zeigen möchte dass man physisch auf
etwas steht auf nutzt man zum beispiel
mit den substantiven die insel und das
land zunächst zeigen wir euch auf mit
dativ
mit urlaub auf dem land ist so
entspannend
das gefällt mir viel besser als ein
städtetrip
ja wir auch
[Musik]
jetzt zeigen wir euch eine szene mit auf
und akkusativ
wohin fahren will am wochenende
vielleicht aufs land nicht schon wieder
mit fragt wohin fahren wir das ist
wieder eine bewegung deshalb brauchen
wir den akkusativ
ich antworte vielleicht aufs land auf
das land nicht auf dem land das wären
nicht da tief für eine position
jetzt zeigen wir euch noch die sehr
häufige präposition in
nutzt man wenn man zeigen möchte dass
man sich in einem gebiet befindet das
sind irgendeiner form geschlossen oder
abtrennbar ist in nutzt man zum beispiel
mit das gebirge der wald oder mit
ländern und städten wir beginnen wieder
mit dem dativ
[Musik]
es ist so heiß
wandern ende hätte es echt anstrengend
[Musik]
als heute
wir könnten im wald spazieren gehen da
ist
ja okay zum schluss zeigen wir euch noch
in mit akkusativ
wohin fährst du morgen ins gebirge
und übermorgen
okay
hier ein wichtiger tipp bei ländern und
städten mit akkusativ sagen wir nach und
nicht in zum beispiel ich fahre nach
deutschland nur bei ländern mit artikel
wie zb die mongolei oder die schweiz
nutzen wir in und einen artikel
und wohin fährst du nächste woche nach
new york nach wien
und in zwei wochen wohin fährst du dann
in die schweiz nach st
du bist viel unterwegs
ihr seht wir sagen nach österreich nach
deutschland und nach großbritannien wir
sagen aber nicht nach usa nach schweiz
und nach türkei sondern in die usa in
die schweiz und in die türkei weil diese
länder einen artikel haben dazu haben
wir auch schon mal ein video gedreht
schaut mal hier und noch ein kleiner
lernte wenn ihr neue wörter lernt zum
beispiel der wald die insel und die
küste merkt euch immer direkt die
passende präposition zusammen mit dem
wort das war unser video für heute wo
seid ihr gerade wohin möchtet ihr gerne
reisen schreibt uns gerne einen
kommentar und wir freuen uns sehr wenn
ihr unsere arbeit unterstützt indem er
mitglied von easy german werdet dann
könnt ihr mit unseren vielen
lernmaterialien noch intensiver deutsch
lernen tschüss und bis bald